all right welcome everybody we
tragically
have had another mass shooting this one
looks like it may be
into the double digits with the death
toll and
many many more injured we're standing by
for a press conference at the bottom of
the hour from california officials
and we'll hopefully learn more about it
um
at that time what we know i probably
will not cover this on the show tomorrow
because what else is there to say
like what how would my coverage be
materially different
about this shooting than the last one in
the previous one in the previous one in
the previous
it's uh it's a problem of epidemic
proportions
and um what we know so far
article from the los angeles times us
nine people including the gunman died in
a mass shooting at san jose light rail
yard
wednesday morning the gunman set his own
house on fire before he drove to a
valley transportation authority union
meeting
and began shooting he was identified as
a 57 year old maintenance worker
at the vta so
you know is this another disgruntled
employee
situation um there are um
you know rumors that this was um a hate
crime
which we'll see at the press conference
at the bottom of the hour what they are
saying
at this point in time investigators
believe there are still explosive
devices at the vta
site light light rail service has been
suspended indefinitely
santa clara county sheriff lori smith
said the building is remote and the area
is cordoned off
so there's no immediate risk to the
public we received information that
there are explosive devices that are
located inside the building
we activated our bomb squad which is
currently out on scene
davis confirmed the suspect was dead but
did not elaborate on the cause of death
he did not say what type of gun was used
sources say the suspect is believed to
have killed himself
after the mass shooting early
indications are that the shooting was
related to a workplace issue and did not
involve rioters of the system
at cassidy's three-bedroom home
investigators discovered firearms and a
large amount of ammunition according to
sources
um no injuries reported at the fire
the belief shooter worked at the light
rail yard for at least eight years
shot virtually everyone on the morning
shift including some people he had
worked with for years
just senseless pointless death his
ex-wife filed a restraining order
against him in 2009.
um what can we say what can we say it's
another one of these incidents
and um we are standing by
for a press conference at the bottom of
the hour
and then we will see what if anything
we learned from that uh and i don't i
don't know
exactly what we will learn from it at
this point in time
i do have things to go over with you
guys you know some of them are like sort
of
jokey and i don't know if it's
inappropriate we have a tragedy here to
do anything that's
jokey i i don't know i mean i guess
we'll see
um one thing that is really weird and
this i probably will cover tomorrow
is that a fox news guest retired new
york police department
detective pat brosnan seemed to weirdly
blame vaccines for this
saying like as more people get
vaccinated more shooters are going to go
go out and do shootings
and this shooter was probably vaccinated
like if you plan to
die in a shooting either at the hands of
police or your own
i don't think you're gonna be worried
about covid it's
one of the most ridiculous takes i could
imagine
just listen to this terms of that crime
scene
uh good morning harris uh actually uh in
a in a rational world
where there's adherence to the rule of
law and respect for law enforcement
say pre uh the summer of love of 2020
i think they would be more the hell is
this guy talking about
wants response in terms of opening a
shooting an active shooting right next
door to where there's a load of
armed uh professional shooters under law
enforcement
but the rules have changed you know
crimes are no longer illegal
uh there's no longer enforcement of lots
of laws what does that mean crimes are
no longer illegal like by definition a
crime is against the law
it's like a verbal ink blot and there's
an empowerment of these active shooters
and you know harris this is a time that
i wish i was wrong with my prediction
which i
mentioned to anybody who listened that
once uh
once coverage starts to lift these
cowardly shooters
uh will come out exactly in tandem with
the number of vaccinations you can be
sure they probably got vaccinated
they were just scared to come out and
they're coming back
you know guys i can't pretend
to know what's going on in the mind of a
mass shooter because it seems
so the opposite of everything that i
could imagine
ever being in a place in my mind but i
don't think if i wanted to do a mass
shooting i would say
let me wait until i'm vaccinated to do
the mass shooting
because i don't want to catch covid
i this is maybe the worst take i've
heard about any
any any shooting ever
the numbers don't lie the shootings are
up dramatically
skyrocketing actually on on active
shootings throughout the united states
yeah and the reason for that you would
imagine is just people are starting to
gather again what the mass shooter needs
is people to be working and
if you want to go and shoot a bunch of
people at work
you've got to make sure that they're at
work and so yes it's true
as we get out of the pandemic people are
going to be in places again
uh is the argument we should stay closed
as a result of that like
this is one of the dumbest takes i've
maybe ever heard
about a mass shooting um so anyway we'll
we'll talk about that tomorrow but just
an
unbelievably boneheaded boneheaded take
um okay
so we're standing by for the for the
press conference at the bottom of the
hour
robert says via super chat i work at a
union seems like a bi-annual event we
have to lock down because someone's
threatening us sad to see brothers and
sisters dead well union or not this is
this is just a tragedy
um yeah that fox guy was a cop
that's crazy that's crazy let me say
thank you to dub fotek for the twitch
sub i appreciate that
also thanks to c missile tangela irene
harry2023
maulbury very much appreciate that guys
thank you and
yeah i'll open some phone lines um also
it's still on the table if we if we get
to the 100 members and twitch subs i'll
open phone lines
and i'll do a new garden video update
that on the next stream
um if people want also glad to just see
what what goes on with this press
conference but there's no shortage of uh
of things to talk about uh coupon code
is working everybody relax
no no need to stress um
oh okay let me um
let me deal with this you know what i've
mentioned before one of the most
frustrating things about just doing a
show
where people react to what you say
and i see the super chat about
christopher hitchens you know i don't
feel like i have to have a strong
opinion about
everything i don't have a super strong
opinion about christopher hitchens i
thought
he said a lot of interesting things not
not everything he said resonated with me
he was clearly a brilliant guy um
and i think a lot was lost when he
passed away but i don't i don't have any
huge opinion about christopher hitchens
um
one of the things that's really
frustrating is when people react
and say david i really disagree with
that thing you said
when it's not something that i actually
said like disagree with me for the
things i've said and then we'll we'll
have a real conversation
this was a really weird post i saw in
the david pakman show subreddit
which by the way almost 31 000 people
subscribed to the subreddit now this is
someone reacting to my mask
comments that i never made comments i
never made okay listen to this
why david pakman doesn't like wearing a
mask
every time mr pacmaniac talks about how
he just follows the cdc guidelines and
how he doesn't wear it outside
gives the impression he's disgusted with
wearing it no no i'm
not disgusted i i just follow cdc
guidelines
i'm not disgusted i get the impression
he doesn't fully understand that wearing
a mask can protect you against catching
cold cough etc from someone else as well
as seasonal influenza in the winter
right but that's not happening outdoors
guys
it's not happening outdoors and when the
cdc said wear a mask outdoors i was
doing it anyway
but he doesn't even hint at that being a
useful habit to adopt for u.s society
when seasonal influenza comes
wrong i've actually said i could see it
being plausible that when we're in the
middle of flu season
maybe grocery stores say let's wear
masks or at-risk people wear masks i've
actually it's this is the opposite of
what i've said
um why is it that these type of entitled
people such as
me in the u.s always feel their freedom
is being violated when they're asked to
do something for someone else i i've not
made the free you know i'm not rand paul
i've not made the freedom argument once
this is not about freedom this is about
we have public health agencies and and i
just follow what they say and when they
said no more masks outdoors i stopped
with masks outdoors that's
it's really weird seems like they just
don't want others telling them what to
do i
never once made a freedom or nanny state
argument about this
i maybe you have maybe you have
my show confused with someone else i
don't know
and some good comments here pacman has
explained his position on mass ad
nauseum go back and watch your
hyperbolic predetermined question shows
you're acting in bad faith already
also do you want to try and convince
everyone in the u.s to wear a mask all
the time
most wouldn't even do it at the peak of
the pandemic what makes you think people
will wear it for seasonal flu
to be clear i don't think it's a bad
personal choice to make to wear a mask
more often
but it's not it's just not happening in
the us at this current moment
many are too stubborn arrogant or
selfish master a medical tool that
should be discarded when they're no
longer medically useful
um i don't think he stated he doesn't
find them useful he frequently discussed
the value of wearing them indoors in
crowded spaces etc he advocated for
their use for a long time
i do think his criticism of the mandate
to wear them outside is valid
the data and study results have at no
point suggest that outdoor wear was
necessary
it's important to state outdoor wearing
is also not effective for limiting the
spread of cold and flu yeah so i'm glad
that usually people in the comments
further attack me
so it's actually a nice change to see
people in the in the comments defending
me people can't even troll correctly
yeah it's it's sad
it's sad that we've come to the point
where even trolls don't know how to
troll
truly a tragedy really
a few other super chats coming in as we
stand by for this press conference
no guns no shootings the usa should ban
guns never going to happen
it's just never going to happen so i
think we should be focusing on things
that we can do as i've outlined before
nehemiah says i like guns and a magona a
gun owner however i don't understand how
other gun owners can be so opposed to
gun licenses registries
and universal background checks when so
many unqualified and unstable americans
have guns
absolutely well said the family asks do
you prefer physical books or e-books
i am 100 on physical books i just have
not made the transition to e-books i
like the physical
book at night when i'm reading in bed i
don't want a device
in there get the devices out of bed
i don't want devices in bed all right
stop bugging me
about switching i get emails from people
even in my family
saying david it's time to stop the paper
books
it is not time to stop the paper books
we are continuing the paper books thank
you
a vegan plantry says happy to join the
live stream sad under these grim
circumstances yes well said and we are
standing by for a press conference here
david do you have any opinions about the
last mile vehicle or electric vehicle
movement now that everything is slowly
opening up last mile vehicle i don't
know is that just
a mile a per mile user fee i i don't
know it by that name you'd have to tell
me a little bit more about that
mass shootings is because of anger
and misery david plus isolation make
mental health support free
therapists mentors life coaches for jobs
and friends
that's a big that's a big that's a big
factor for sure
no question about it welcome if you're
just joining us i wish it were under
better circumstances we have had another
mass shooting this one in san jose
california
nine dead including the shooter and
shooter
identified as a 57 year old man who
apparently wired his house to no i'm
sorry burned his house down
and so we are standing by for a press
conference i do have a few
uh unban requests i don't hold on let me
see if i can reach my gavel
here it is let me look at these unbanned
requests the first one is from a user
named yabba dabba-doo
who let's see why were they banned
they said if this is woke i'd rather
sleep
reject politics embrace gardening
lol israel
just like fascism is undefined none of
this stuff seems bad
don't get the vaccine guys stay safe
okay they were banned yeah yeah yeah so
i see
everything was fine until they got into
don't get the vaccine
and then their unbanned request is don't
see why i'm banned never argued in bad
faith and would like an
unban no that's it's perma unfortunately
because we just don't do anti-vaxx stuff
it's just that's just a hard line
we just don't do it another user x kirby
z
was banned
they said do you use cdc guidelines to
wipe your butt david
they were banned and then they said i
was being sarcastic
okay yeah that's i will unban
and adjudicated that's fine that was
more of like a time out and okay
you know we we have a sense of humor
here that's okay um
excuse me that's the f we've had i think
seven perma bands in a row
and uh it's nice to finally be able to
unban someone so very very nice um
okay if you're just joining us you've
not missed the press
conference we are standing by for the
press conference um
i also have a bunch of other things to
go over with you this is a very
interesting documentary called
cue a mom and it's about a guy whose mom
is total q conspiracy theorist
it's disturbing but i want to check it
out also
the woman um running the
or who's at the head of the arizona
election
audit or ardet some say she was
confronted by cnn
and it's really really good
and then um i want to review people
yesterday liked this so i wanted to
review my interview with this white
supremacist craig cobb who uh
actually introduced the term [ __ ]
wordsmithing
during our interview and it was pretty
pretty vile uh
so those are things on tap but we are
standing by for this
this press conference imminently
imminently starting
i will both open phone lines and do an
updated
um garden video if we get to 100 website
members and twitch subs
remember if you're new here the best way
and i really do mean the best way to
support the work that we do
is to grab a membership at
joinpackman.com
you get everything free that's good when
you sign up at joinpakman.com and the
coupon code for a discount is
immoral 21 immoral 21
immoral 21 so i'll thank everybody who
signs up
and we're going just be best be best
everybody
eugene vernikov says smart guns anyone
yeah those are the guns where
i believe it's fingerprint based the gun
will only work if it recognizes the
fingerprint
republicans hate it they just absolutely
hate it
another user says via super chat if no
gun ban is possible instead of universal
basic income universal body armor
let's see what else we got get the
devices out of bed
oh my god that that's a little too edgy
that's a little too edgy for the show
um michael says hi hackman what's up
with
really low live stream views sometimes
the views are up sometimes the views are
down we're just doing our thing
channel keeps growing all going well
junie says why is the american right
wing so vehemently against the vaccine
that the right wing
then the right wing in other countries
israel with its right-wing government
has over 55 percent of its population
fully vaccinated oh it's much more than
that
all right let's get to the press
conference about uh their investigation
and um what they are doing now to
provide resources and help
to the victims and their families there
you see the santa clara county
spokesman russell davis who has been
briefing us all morning
and yeah let's get started everyone good
good afternoon my name is deputy russell
davis
santa clara county sheriff's office
public information officer
before we start i'd like to put all my
thoughts and prayers
to the victims and their families of
what happened today
this is a tragic situation that we're
dealing with right now and we're using
all the resources we have right now to
find out what exactly happened and what
transpired
our first primary focus is public safety
we want to ensure everything that
happened from today is we will ensure
the biggest public safety
for the surrounding area in our whole
community
this morning at 6 30 4 in the morning
santa clara county communications
received 911 phone calls
of a shots fired call in the area of 101
west younger avenue located in the city
of san jose
which is directly adjacent right next
door to sheriff's office headquarters
[Music]
deputies responded and received
information that their multiple shots
fired calls
located from that building during this
time
this was during a shift change
where deputies from the midnight shift
and day shift were on at the same time
going through a transition into
different shifts
once we received that information
deputies and surrounding officers
immediately responded
to the location and address the threat
in the situation they did not wait they
immediately went into the scene
and rendered first aid and rescued
victims out of the building as fast as
they can
to figure out what was going on i could
tell you this was
a at a valley transportation authority
light rail yard
which is next door to sheriff's office
headquarters
immediately once we received information
of shots fired called
we immediately activated the santa clara
county active shooter protocol
which activated multiple law enforcement
agencies in the surrounding counties
as well as multiple fire department
agencies
to initiate and activate the rescue task
force which is part of the active
shooter protocol
which will go into more detail
multiple agencies showed up and assisted
from local agencies within santa clara
county
state level from the office emergency
services governor's office
the california highway patrol and
multiple federal agencies
from the federal bureau investigations
fbi
atf and department of homeland security
i'll tell you right now with the numbers
and it's still preliminary and it's
subject to change
we have eight victims that are
pronounced deceased from today's
incident
from gunshot wounds so nine includes the
shooter we also have one suspect
who is deceased as well right from this
morning's incident
i can confirm with you that deputies did
not exchange gunfire
and right now we're going to preliminary
go with the assumption that it was a
self-inflicted gunshot wound from
the suspect and deputies did not
exchange gunfire at this point
we have investigators on scene
interviewing anybody that was on scene
to see what exactly happened
and we have our csi teams as well
outside with along with conjunction with
the federal bureau of investigations
assisting
right now if you are looking for a
family member loved one involved with
this incident
we ask you to contact our reunification
center which is over here at 70 west
heading
it's located at the isaac newton
auditorium
we have grief counselors on scene the
phone number to call
is 408 209-8356
i'll repeat it one more time
408-209-8356
so this incident is going to take some
time and the reason why is because
we're going to use all necessary methods
to ensure the public safety for everyone
we actually had an explosives dog on
scene which detected to some type of
explosives material
at the crime scene itself at that point
we activated the sheriff's office bomb
squad
who is currently on scene and render any
type of
suspicious packaging safe at that point
i'll tell you it's going to take a long
time
to render these areas safe they have to
go through every room
and every building to ensure that
everything is safe
so that such is in bringing in um a bomb
robot
in there and it takes time so i ask for
your patience on gathering further
information from here
it's gonna be some time other than that
we have detectives on scene
we're doing everything we can but i'll
tell you this with the training that
we've been doing with our active shooter
protocol
this could have been a lot worse of a
situation this is a very unfortunate
situation
but with the training and everything
that we have with this protocol
this this could have been a lot worse
than what it was unfortunately
so that being said i'm going to pass it
on to sheriff lori smith who's going to
give you further information from there
the bomb squad is pretty much activated
and they're searching every crevice of
the whole building
to ensure that everything is safe and
that's where it's going to take some
time
the vta transit center which is a light
well it's pretty much a light rail
facility pretty much light world garage
homeland security is involved you know
you know we appreciate having federal
agencies coming out they come out here
just to provide resources for us hey do
you need any assistance and
you know in that case and if we need
help we'll ask them out in that case so
they're just being an entity to help us
out
it depends how big this building is i
haven't been in the building myself but
it's going to take some time
so i ask you for that patience
[Music]
any occasional motive we don't have that
information right now this is still
preliminary this is still ongoing
all the information i have is i can get
at this point and we're still getting as
we get along
i'm guessing what it means but it could
have been worse is when this started
a lot of people at the facility probably
locked themselves in
and and that probably prevented even
more death i'm guessing
so this is a big building i can't get
into details how big this building is
but it's a pretty
pretty decent sized building in regards
with motive i don't have that
information this is still preliminary
and i'm still trying to get that
information at this point
we know that shootings took place inside
outside or either
we don't i don't know at this point if
it's inside or outside we have
yeah i'm gonna pass it off to sheriff
lori smith and then she's gonna take
over from here
so what i'd first like to do is
tell everyone that my heart really goes
out to the victims
these were county employees and we're
doing everything we can to help them
including the family reunification
center but i really want to commend
the law enforcement in santa clara
county several years ago
the sheriff's office in conjunction with
the county fire department
began a series of trainings for active
shooter
and that training has happened
throughout the county with law
enforcement and all fire agencies
and why that differs is that at the time
there's an
active shooter as soon as we can get one
team together we go in
the first teams through the door were
the sheriff's office and san jose police
department
and they're they're my true heroes there
was active shooting going on at that
time
there were victims shot in two separate
buildings
but they responded they responded the
way that they should
they took their life in their hands and
i know for sure
that when the suspect
knew oh
so that's dumb
that's their feeling sounds like we are
having a bit of a technical issue there
the
uh signal has frozen at the moment but
you're listening to sheriff
laurie smith talk about what happened
there
saying just now some new information
that victims were shot in two
separate buildings there at the vta
railyard so two separate buildings is
where this took place we don't know if
it was inside
and or outside they have not said but
two different buildings and also saying
that active gunfire was taking place
when first responders and police
officers a lot of relevant super chats
coming in i do
sheriff's office and san jose police
entered
the rail yard so you know sheriff lori
smith saying they are the true heroes
today they put their lives on the lines
and entered during active gunfire
yes they rescue people when they got
there
she was i think about to say that
the gunman when he realized that law
enforcement were there and he had no way
out
that may have been the point at which um
he shot himself
decided to take his life yes that's that
is what it appears hopefully they get
this feedback because i actually thought
that we were learning quite a bit about
what's going on
um i do want to say thanks to a whole
bunch of people who grabbed twitch prime
subscriptions appreciate that
also thank you very much to jesus
armando
figueroa salido who just grabbed a
membership at jointpakman.com very much
appreciate that
i'm also being told that gavin newsom is
speaking so let me see if i can grab
that
a lot worse than what we could imagine
with eight people killed before the
gunman shot himself
um but yes one thing of course liz that
they pointed out is that this is going
to take a long time
that this process is going to be long
because they have to go through every
crevice we've got it here
[Music]
just here in this community down in
southern california
and san bernadino remember a few years
prior in
santa barbara pick a state
and here we are in the united states of
america we're experiencing something
just
not experienced anywhere else in the
world there's a sameness to this
and that numbness i think is something
we're all feeling
all of us gathered here today looking at
the scene
listening to governors mayors chiefs
speaking similar tone and terms
expression of condolences all the right
emotions and
perhaps the right words but it begs the
damn question what the hell is going on
in the united states of america
the hell is wrong with us and when are
we going to come to grips with this when
are we going to put down
our arms literally and figuratively our
politics stale rhetoric
finger-pointing all a hand-wringing
consternation that produces nothing
except more fury and frustration
more scenes like this repeated over and
over and over again i say that
not as a governor and say that as a
father of four
i say that as a member of this community
cares deeply about it
so we'll we'll have time to work through
all of that but one thing i just wanted
to briefly speak to
is the pain in those victims
i just spent we just had the privilege
spending last few hours
with the victims that are waiting
to just learn if their loved one is
still alive they're down on the phones
they can't find it
they're trying to go on and find a phone
with a loved one
when you hear from the corner waiting to
hear from any of us just desperate to
find out
if their brother their son their dad
their mom is still alive imagine
being in there i know everybody wants
all the answers to all these questions
but there's no more important question
and no more important answers than we
owe
been the victims of this senseless and
tragic shooting
and so i'm not just going to express my
condolences i'm not just going to
express the usual platitudes but let me
just think the heroism of those victims
the fact that i can even stand up and
support one another
is remarkable but a human act
and so i just want to uh
we just want folks to know we're going
to be there for the victims
i want folks to know you know i'm here
for you mr mayor and the county
uh this state and uh and i know
we have elected officials of all
political strives who want to be here
for this nation what audio but it's time
time to deal with the endemic
before this pendulum of gun violence the
pre-existing condition
it somehow sort of pushed aside last
year but now has raised its ugly head
again this year and wake up to this
reality and take a little damn
responsibility
all of us to do a little bit more and a
little bit better this time
and move beyond the platitudes and
the usual rhetoric that tends to mark
not just these moments
but the aftermath of these moments as
all of you go away
and this fades out of you and then we
rinse and repeat someplace else
in this country so again to the victims
to those that lost their lives and their
families
lost their loved ones yes our hearts go
out but
we are resolved to not make this
meaningless but to bring meaning
of this tragic moment in our state in
our nation's history
again thank you to all the men and women
behind me in their courageousness and
the incredible
incredible bravery that was demonstrable
of the men and women our san jose police
department and sheriff's office
governor what do you say to the people
who say california has some of the
toughest gun laws
so next we're going to introduce valley
transportation authority
chair president glenn hendricks
see if the other feed came back now
as you all know a horrible tragedy has
impacted the bta family
the organization and our whole community
and our thoughts and love go out to all
the employees who have been directly
and indirectly impacted by this horrible
event
i want to let you know that the families
have been moved to the family assistance
center at the red cross
to continue to have meet with counselors
about what's happening
we're really grateful for the outpouring
of support that has come from
union leadership and transit
organizations from across the country
the vta has suspended its light rail
service and will probably be suspended
for several days
as we work through being able to get
back into the yard
we'll be setting up bus bridges to go
ahead and help get our customers around
we're asking that our customers be
patient with us as we work through this
event to try and recover our service
and i also want to thank all the law
enforcement that's been involved
in their quick reaction in the way
they've been dealing with
everyone who's involved by this and once
again i want to say how
terribly sorry i am and want to thank
everybody in the vta family who's been
so effective
next we're going to introduce the
president of the county board of
supervisors for santa clara county
mike wasserman and county supervisor
cindy johnson
it was two years ago mass shooting in
gilroy
and law enforcement responded quickly
and minimized the number of fatalities
last year we had coveted still have
covered the last year was the big year
and the people and the county responded
so as to have the lowest positivity rate
in the state today we have this mass
shooting here
and it was the santa clara county
sheriff's department and the san jose
police department
that responded so quickly to minimize
the loss of lives
as you can see our flag now is at half
mask
to help commemorate and remember the
people that have passed today
it is an extremely sad day in the
history of santa clara county
but i'm also very proud of the response
by law enforcement
and then the vta family taking care
of the loved ones the survivors of those
that pass
and the district attorney's office that
has stepped forth
with the services they've provided two
years ago to the people in gilroy
and continue to provide every day that
will provide
to the survivors loved ones and family
of those that passed it is a sad day in
santa clara county history
but i'm very proud of the response
including the unions
that have come forward with funding and
help
santa clara county is a family and
you're seeing that go into effect today
my condolences to all the family members
and friends
of those that passed today
you know let me let me start by just
reminding everybody that um the backbone
of santa clara county throughout kobit
19 was all the essential workers and
none were more essential
than making sure people we've got better
audio here making sure people could get
to their places of work
and vta never stopped it didn't stop
light rail it didn't stop buses it
didn't stop helping move people from
point a to point b
these heroes that we we all learned how
to call essential workers heroes
we're now calling on them to be heroes
again
there's a fund that's been set up for
these families but and by going to
workingpartnerships.org anybody who
wants to make a contribution to the
families that have been
impacted the vta families that have been
impacted can do that
directly by going to working
partnerships usa.org
i just want to close with this point
while my heart breaks i can't stop
thinking about what we could all be
doing differently to stop this in our
community so
this doesn't become something that just
happens here but something that should
never happen
and thank all of you for being here
thank you i'm going to introduce the
mayor of san jose sam la carta
[Music]
it's been said before but it's worth
saying again our hearts are broken
for the family members who have lost
their loved ones for vta family members
who have lost their friends and
colleagues
i'm joined here by councilmember raul
peralta himself lost a dear friend
uh council member matt mahan
uh these are members of our community
these are members of our families
and right now this moment is for morning
and for supporting those families and
friends and loved ones
and we're going to do everything we can
here at the city with all of our
partners and i'm so grateful for how
everyone has stepped up the valley
transportation authority in the county
and to have the governor come down here
lily came down here said
i don't need to speak to anybody on any
stage or anything
oh no not again
man this feed is just not good has
frozen up once again
i guess we'll go back here part of our
community and how we care in times of
tragedy
tomorrow we're going to have a visual at
6 pm
at san jose city hall we know that
our entire community will need this
moment and many others to mourn
together and so we want to bring people
together
to be able to at least share a common
humanity
particularly given all that we've been
through over the last year and a half
this is a time when we need to be
together
i want to thank working partnerships usa
and south bay labor council for setting
up
a fund and we encourage anyone who wants
to give to help support
families in this difficult time to
please give generously to that fund
these are this counts as supervisor
chavez said so well these are you know
we expect sort of
platitudes like this and it's great that
all these people are here
but there's no change on the horizon on
this issue of gun violence there just
isn't i mean
oh so now something's gonna change when
we you know
we just hear the exact same stuff i mean
it's just infuriating
we owe them and their families so much
and i am so grateful for the san jose
police department and the sheriff's
office that responded so quickly
undoubtedly saving lives as a result
we will continue to show our resolve as
a community to come together
and as the governor indicated we've got
a lot of work to do to start to work on
solutions
yeah we're all sad again we're all
recognizing the tragedy again
we're all praying for the families of
the victims and we're donating money to
them and we're holding a vigil
and we're calling for action and you
know
okay not saying the mayor of san jose
can fix this by the way special agent in
charge of the san francisco office
craig fair
just like how long will we do nothing i
guess is the question the special agent
charge
of the san francisco division of the fbi
here in the bay area
on behalf of the fbi i would like to
express our condolences
to the families and victims vta family
and to the city of san jose in the wake
of this
tragic crisis of which the fbi is no
stranger
to responding to
the fbi is assisting the city of san
jose the san jose police department and
their santa clara sheriff's office in
this investigation
they are lead we are providing
assistance in the form
of evidence response and recovery
we are flying national assets from
quantico virginia
we will be providing ballistics
technical forensic
analysis we will be bringing teams in
from other divisions
throughout the fbi to assist in the
analysis of privacy
that is going to take some time it is
complex
we are very deliberate we
are required to map catalog evidence
and that is going to take some time and
i'm asking your patients
in that process we are also providing
victim assistance victim services
during this crisis to help families heal
[Music]
we will be here as long as needed and
continue to provide that assistance i
would also like to commend the first
responders
the officers who went in at their own
peril
to assist in taking out victims
thank you very much special agent could
you describe a little bit how complex
this is it looks like it's multiple
buildings you're already starting the
map and i see some of that
this is a really you're talking multiple
locations right
it is multiple locations it is as i said
it's a very sizable crime scene
we are currently in there um looking at
how we need to go and how we need to
process that that is also going to take
some time before we actually start
in processing i'm with you guys you know
it's like of course they have to do this
and it's like how many times have we
heard the crime scene is big and it's
wide and it's long and all of this stuff
okay right but what could could we
prevent something maybe
joshua jackson
hey good afternoon my name is joshua
jackson i'm the assistant special agent
in charge
with the atf san francisco field
division hf definitely wants to express
our deepest condolences to the victims
who lost their lives were injured the
families
and friends of those individuals as well
as
community at large who are suffering at
this time
atf is here supporting this
investigative effort
as well as providing all of our experts
and firearms
arson explosives include our certified
fire investigators
our certified explosive specialists as
well as our
explosive detection canines in addition
to our personnel we're also providing
firearm ballistics information
resources related to our national
integrated politicalistic
information network from kniven as well
as tracing
atf is committed to reducing violent
crime throughout all the communities
that we serve throughout the united
states
and we're committed to to see this one
through uh supporting our
investigative partners here in this
investigative team thank you joshua can
you talk about the different dogs
we've seen like all times they have
different specialties can you call them
did you say dogs
i can comment on the atf explosive
detection canines that we have
currently we have five atf explosive
detection
canines that have been deployed to
support investigative efforts
and uh those canines are being deployed
uh on the scene
right now talk about the importance of
knives in this case
of knives what are people saying as far
as
it provides atf and our investigative
resources the ability to be able to
trace
firearms and ballistics evidence to link
it to other fire
other firearm crimes or other crimes
that might be involved
it's not to say that this the evidence
here has not been processed for nothing
yet the crime scene is still being
processed as we speak evidence is still
being uh taken into custody
that will take place at a later date
thank you we'll use diamond is that
correct
so we're gonna pass it off next to san
jose police department chief anthony
mata
good afternoon i want to extend my
serious condolences
to the victims family and our community
there's no doubt that the courageous
acts
of our men and women at the san jose
police department
saved lives and helped rescue the over
40 employees that were
present at this facility again i'm
extremely proud at the partnership that
we have with our service department
the fire department our federal partners
again to limit the loss and the tragedy
that has occurred today
we are here to support our community our
families
and our law enforcement partners as we
are help them with their investigation
thank you for your continued support of
the san jose police department
and of all law enforcement here in the
county
next we're going to introduce the san
jose fire department chief robert
sapiens jr
good afternoon my name is robert
sapienza fire department fire chief
this morning at about 6 30 a.m three
significant
incidents unfolded that required us to
mobilize all of our on-duty available
resources
unfortunately the second of those events
was
the younger incident where our personnel
were dispatched to an emergency medical
service let's switch feeds again
ultimately we learned it was this active
shooter event
our personnel very quickly employed
their training and equipment which
allows them to
tactically integrate with law
enforcement officers
in today's event there is some relief
in reporting to you that the operations
could not have gone more
efficiently or effectively the training
that our firefighters receive
in cooperation with our law enforcement
partners
allows them to treat trauma victims
as quickly as possible to give them
their best chance
at survival at today's event as i said
operations ran as trained
and so we are very
thankful that we were able to be here to
provide assistance
we are very sad for the losses in our
community
and we continue to be present uh to
support our community
thank you
the fire there was a shooting and what
else there so i'm going to introduce
next is a
gene cohen from the south bay labor
council
good afternoon my name is gene cohen i'm
the executive officer of the south bay
labor council
we are here with all the working men and
women in santa clara county to stand
with our atu brothers and sisters
today is about supporting victims it's
about sending love
and support to everyone who came to work
this morning intending on serving the
public
and ended up not going home it's
unacceptable and what we're asking for
right now is for there to be respect
and love that's dedicated and shown to
all of these workers
they need money they need support and we
need to make sure that their families
are also being respected in terms of
giving them their space
to mourn so thank you so much for the
opportunity to make sure that all of our
workers
have the opportunity to let you know
that when you go to work you should be
able to go back safely
and that right now we're going to be
making sure that as a family we're
taking care of each other
thank you very much
oh and there goes the feed again
go we'll go back to the one with the
terrible audio saying this is an
active sheriff's office investigation
and
we will continue to provide you updates
but again
the deputy sheriffs from the sheriff's
office the officers from san jose police
department
ran into the building the shots were
being fired and i know that it saved
many lives
thanks to the fire department also so
being
part of our active shooter protocol and
our rescue team
so we had some heroics that i think
resulted in
a diminished
loss of life you know we're real proud
of the people who have
who serve in this county that responded
to this incident
and we will take some questions and
um you can direct the questions that any
of the speakers if you would like
[Music]
regards with fatalities and locations
like i've seen earlier it's still
preliminary at this point
so one we have to get the sheriff's
office bomb squad in there to clear the
area
four investigators will go in and
conduct their investigation so this is
going to be a very timely methodical
situation so it's going to take a lot of
time so i don't have that information
though
[Music]
it's within that facility area i don't
have those answers at this point it's
still preliminary
it can be either i don't have that
information at this point
[Music]
so on top of the on top of the
fatalities that i mentioned there is one
person at a local
trauma hospital with that's listed in
critical condition at this point
uh legal gun owner and can you say what
the weapon was that you used
right now i don't have that information
in regards to what weapon was used in
that information
so are there bodies that are still
inside the facility that you have not
been able to recover and remove yet and
is that
why there has been some delay in in
definitively telling families
what's happened to loved ones that they
can't get in contact with them
yeah so we have investigators on scene
with the santa clara county coroner's
office right now
so they're doing their investigation to
follow up to see what they have and also
contact the next of kin
we just want to make sure we ensure the
privacy for the family and loved ones
that were involved in this situation
i'm sorry that's the ongoing
weapons regarding with the the suspect's
house we don't have that information
right now it's still on point
between the fire at his house and the
shooting did the fire
erupt before he left to so i know
there's some speculation saying there's
a house fire within the city of san jose
and then something involved with this
again we're using the investigators to
determine if there is any type of
connection to that case but right now
it's still preliminary and ongoing
i don't have that information at this
point so so he can't say anything else
really
any other questions were discovered or
indicated by
an explosive dog in the building correct
so there's an
explosive detection dog an eod dog is
what we call that detected on a
suspicious device
immediately we activated the santa clara
county sheriff's office bomb squad
and they're going to use their protocol
and pretty much canvas that whole area
to ensure that it's safe
for our investigators to go in and
conduct their investigation at that
point so it's going to be a very
timely methodical we're going to be
there throughout the night to
clear every room and every crevice of
that building we know
that is a very big building and we're
going to use everything because we want
to ensure
the safety for the deputies and
investigators and everyone else around
um that it's it's clear and safe are
they just searching the building or they
will they also search the light rail
trains
tracks the area around we're going to
search everywhere we're going to do
everything in all our
and all do for us and we're going to use
all the resources that we have
and that's why we have multiple
surrounding law enforcement agencies
here
including federal agencies to assist us
uh with this investigation
i don't know if it was a drive by it was
a passerby or somebody inside the
building that called 911 but it got
received to us at 6 30 for this morning
[Music]
i don't know if they're in the same
place i know that they were employees
i'll tell you that the suspect that was
that was um
deceased is an employee from vta one
more question then we're gonna wrap it
up
i'm sorry can you describe the
explosives that were found explosives
we're still it's still preliminary we're
trying to
we're the bomb squad's doing everything
they can to utilize and find
everything we're going to use everything
from precursor chemicals to any type of
explosive devices
to any type of objects and materials
we're going to use all of that and
determine exactly what
one has anymore been found or is it just
the one for right now
once we have one type of when the dog
smells on something and has a scent
we're going to activate the bomb squad
we're going to utilize those resources
from here
[Music]
i don't know that's still again
preliminary and then we're still still
trying to get that information
what i'll tell you right now just to
wrap things up this is our last press
conference
for today we're going this incident
again please give us patience and time
with us we want to be very methodical
very transparent and make sure we do a
thorough investigation on this so please
give us time
i know you want more information please
bear with us and then once we have more
information we will send out an updated
press release department a press release
statement from our agency okay
thank you everybody
all right
thank you for the question a little more
information on the three incidents so
at 0 6 29 this morning
we received a report of fire on smith
avenue which is a commercial area of
town
or commercial industrial rather that
ultimately
was a second alarm fire the
second incident as i said was this
incident here on younger
and the latter was in a residential area
in town on agmar court that's
a-n-g-n-a-r
port and that ultimately uh
was a second alarm fire and then what
time did that third call today
the third call was at uh 0
6 36 hours
the information i have is that the fire
on angmar is under investigation and
that's all i know at this time
[Music]
our firefighters are equipped with
ballistic protection uh which is uh
the bulletproof vest and goggles
all right we're probably at the point
where we're not going to learn anything
else from this
um looks like they're trying to wrap it
i do not have reports of fatalities
so we're gonna wrap up this pressed uh
press statement um everyone here will be
here for individual interviews if you're
interested and then
we'll wrap that up thank you everyone
for coming out
all right so there it is not a lot of
clarity and certainly no feeling
whatsoever that now we're definitely
going to deal with this issue of
shootings in the united states
um so that is that uh shane says i guess
ben shapiro's stupid movie didn't
fix the shooting epid epidemic did it no
uh christopher says i realized two years
ago if you can't beat him join him we on
the left need to stop waiting for gun
control
and take control by getting a gun a
statement many disagree with
but many agree with as well and even
people i know personally
who have reacted the same way all right
let's look at a couple of other things
this is a documentary called
cua mom a guy interviewed his mom about
all of the
conspiracies and delusions that she
believes and
it's pretty depressing it's pretty
depressing check this out pretty much
every conversation
hey mom you wearing a mask when you go
out these days
i don't believe we've had a pandemic i
believe it was a plandemic if you look
at rockefeller's
lockstep it was planned in 2010 it's all
laid out exactly
it has to do with a new world order okay
but we can all agree that these
wildfires are pretty intense right
oh i do not believe the wildfires in
california and oregon are natural
i've actually seen the games in many
videos so i believe
blue beans definitely direct energy
weapons
maybe we just need a good laugh you want
to watch some stephen colbert tonight
i definitely feel he's a pedophile
definitely
because he makes jokes at pizzagate and
everything the people that make
all the jokes about it saying it's not
real they're trying to diffuse it he's a
big part of it
all right let's just talk about music
did you hear the new lady gaga album
she's really a bad satanic she's really
into
the spirit cooking i've seen pictures of
her at the spirit cooking where they're
eating human
meat and they have like a naked body in
the middle of the table
and she was starting to get a little
scared that's when i decided that the
best
way to put her ideas to the test was the
old-fashioned way
by betting some cold hard cash
100 on each one 100 on each one so what
what is bet number one bet number one is
by april 1st
biden will not be in office okay
bet number two is that obama and hillary
and nancy pelosi and brennan
and comey will all be how could this
person work
any job like what job could you work
if you're this delusional
i don't want to name too many names but
i'm just going to say a hundred dollars
at a star hollywood
people in the music and in hollywood
will be arrested for pedophilia and
satanic
um worshiping and sacrifices
i'll give you some examples right she
could be a multi yeah
this is the only job i could see her
working would be
hey would you like me to help you start
your own home based business where you
can make anywhere from a hundred to ten
thousand dollars a day yeah
exactly i think that that's really all
she could do is tom hanks
um imagine if we find out she's a brain
surgeon
oprah okay i think it'll be a hundred
percent proven
with no dispute that uh huge election
fraud with the dominion machines
also i think it's going to be proven
that capitol hill on january
6 was definitely antiva antiva
antiva and black lives matter and it was
a hundred percent arranged
right now i believe that fema and the
military
are in control why there's all this is
this a separate bet
yeah is this funny i can't tell or is
this just scary
because i do believe the pope will be
arrested for
uh being a pedophile and
you know what's funny about the pope
thing when someone says the pope will be
arrested the first question i have is
by what authority will italian
law enforcement enter vatican city
and like there's a jurisdictional issue
there that's it's like it's not like it
matters to these people but that's just
like
i would immediately go to that child
molestation
and you're going to see some proof soon
and you are going to be
shocked to the core you probably won't
be able to get out of bed in the morning
and you're gonna probably call your
mother and say
i can't believe all the crazy crap that
you showed me all these years is really
true
omg you were right mom so this is the
fantasy that
you live in no i think it's gonna happen
yeah this is marjorie taylor green's mom
that's the secret
before she got deep into all this stuff
she used to just be into a lot of quirky
new age health stuff
things like foot baths protecting
herself from electromagnetic frequencies
and these lasers yeah so as you can see
and we've talked to conspiracy
experts before it's an all of the above
with a lot of these people
how she got from point a to point b
i will never understand i've begged her
many times to stop sending me
anything through the internet a lot of
the things she sends me tend to take
over my screen and i can't get them to
stop
she feels like she wants to know she's
sending what she's sending spyware too
that's brilliant
the truth and so she feels like when
she's watching these things
that it really is the truth but i keep
trying to tell her all the time that um
it's almost a fool's errand to think
that you always know what
the truth is i'm very pleased that she
doesn't care that i am not on board 100
with everything that she thinks
she's fine with me going my way
and her going her way so i think that as
far as marriage goes it's great
it seems great yeah if you're just
joining us this is cue imam a guy who
documented his mom's
complete conspiratorial delusions i
think there was
like everything gradual i think when she
first got it she probably just used it
for making
telephone calls and um
then as time went on yeah i'd say that
she's pretty much on her phone
most of the day dear god
if she could be in a room all day and
just watch one video after the other
she also has a mildly confused look
every time she's reading something on
the phone
but once again not all addictions are
bad
i don't think what are some other good
addictions
uh
meditating i'd call that more of like
you've
built up the habit of meditating i don't
know that i'd say it's an
[Music]
addiction
[Music]
all right mother so what do you got in
your hand there seven benjamins that i'm
not very happy to depart with i feel
like i
easily won the election fraud
it wasn't for these facts checkers the
debunk i believe i didn't think fax
machines were even a factor in all this
it's real all right well any final
thoughts about what we learned here
today
i was thinking of doubling my money of
course so i was thinking i was going to
win
but now i realize the way everything
works i was too optimistic
see this is the thing about conspiracy
theorists
she doesn't think so the things she bet
on didn't happen
but she doesn't think they didn't happen
because
she her understanding of the facts is
wrong
[Music]
she believes it's just that she was too
optimistic that they would be dealt with
you see how that works i still believe
they're all true
right right you can't think that all
these people were arrested
they should have been right
yep there you go
[Music]
not have a uh pandemic or epidemic
we also state that coffee 19 should not
be on list
a for any reason
i'm not sure exactly what i expected i
knew these bets weren't gonna suddenly
change her mind and make her give up on
all these conspiracies
but at the end of the day i think they
did make her a little bit less confident
in them
pretty interesting nicely done nicely
done little documentary that's by
dirty sean who only has 759 subscribers
incredibly let's see if that went up
while we were watching
because people must be liking this uh
oh it looks like he lost subscribers
while we were watching that's weird
anyway very nicely done documentary and
and really disturbing stuff
big thank you to josh the the jerk for
signing up on
via twitch prime number 19 today i
appreciate that also a little mini dump
of memberships at joinpakman.com i want
to say thank you to
gage knowles and bradley donovan
who just signed up at joinedpakman.com
and are new members 20 and 21
consider yourself i'm not talking about
you really you consider yourself invited
to sign up at joinpackman.com
haldol harry says from the standpoint of
medical what approach is needed to
control these q people
should we put my username in the water
supply do they even drink water
oh we gotta be careful with water
because with water that water is another
way that they're controlling us you
gotta be really really careful with that
really careful all right so there's
cuamom
speaking of conspiracies a cnn reporter
con
confronted karen fan who's the arizona
state senate president who's kind of
like the
the impetus behind this audit or ardet
happening in arizona let's listen to a
little bit of that
confrontation but why wouldn't we want
to answer those questions dude
you're questioning democracy no i'm
questioning the integrity
of the election system which is the
backbone of democracy that's right
which means we should have full 100
confidence
in our democracy and in our election
system so the see the thing is
a classic move by conspiracy theorists
is to reverse the burden of proof
and to do what karen just did which is
don't you want to be 100 confident that
there was no fraud
we should be 100 confident and the the
question would be
do you have reason to believe we should
not be confident
and do you have reason to believe that
the alleged irregularities are
materially significant and might have
actually impacted the election results
of even a single state
you can't let them reverse the burden of
proof conspiracy theorists love to do
that
but you're talking about trying to
disprove
conspiracies if i have to yes why
wouldn't we
if somebody says as something is out
there
i would love to be able to say that's
not true guys aren't you raising more
questions by giving
rise to these conspiracy theories no i'm
answering questions
after declining a dozen requests from
cnn to talk we finally caught up with
her in the senate parking lot
despite previous audits in maricopa
county that found no widespread fraud
check this out i think i think they show
video of the different techniques
they're applying check this out
fan says this third review is needed
over the last month
we've seen this little known
subcontractor the republican-led senate
hired cyber ninjas use
uv lights check this out did you see
look at these people with a flashlight
look at this they've got the ballot in a
black box
darkened box with a flashlight hunting
for
non-existent watermarks on ballots and
high-tech cameras look at that
look at these cameras looking for did
you see the guy wearing a bass pro shops
hat
that's a specialist for foreign fibers
and photocopy ballots
here's why says fan okay so let me ask
you a question
are you 100 percent confident
that every vote that came in in arizona
or any other state or
can you say emphatically 100 percent
that no
dead people voted that ballots weren't
dead people don't vote so yes i can be
100 confident about that
filled out by other people that the
chain of custody from the minute
people's uh voted their ballots this is
the reversal of the burden of proof
karen do you have reason to believe that
there were such
irregularities that are materially
significant to the
election results it's not whether the
cnn reporter is 100
confident about every ballot it's do we
have any reason to do all of this stuff
if we don't even have evidence that
would have materially affected the
election results
chain of custody was accurate and and on
target the entire time can you tell me
that
i can say that what the data shows us no
there was
no widespread fraud i i didn't say there
was fraud but you just said chain of
custody
yeah chain accounts people that's these
things are all fraud
well i've asked you a question
why is it that it's up to others to
prove there was no fraud
or otherwise you audit every vote like
that's just that's just not the way it
works you have to bring a cause you have
to make a case
that there's a reason to do this can you
honestly tell me
in all the states that no ballots from
people that already deceased
were not filled out and sent in i can
tell you that what the data has shown
overwhelmingly is that elections this
was most the most secure election
in american history okay but you can't
answer that question either can you
see the i wish the reporter attacked the
question
i i'm i'm answering it i'm telling you
no you're telling me what the data says
well what we care about is data i hate
to tell you karen i asked you and you
were asking is what we should be driven
by
what the facts are may be the disconnect
band defense the pro donald trump media
organization one american news network
as being the only outlet given extensive
access to the review
first of all when we talk about
transparency from day one
the entire process has been live
streaming
so anybody on oan with cameras
controlled by oauth are you saying that
oan is not
are you saying that okay i'll remember
that cnn is saying that oen is not
incredible yeah no write that down in
your notebook karen
yes okay very good oan personalities
have fundraised for the arizona audit
and a pro-trump non-profit claims it has
raised 1.7 million for the audit
fan says imagine donating to this when
the audit nears its end
the public will learn who is exactly
paying for this
for now she says taxpayers are covering
the first 150 thousand dollars
well we are paying the 150 000 we are
paying for some of the security and we
were paying for
the cost of the coliseum well we're
paying for our fair share anything over
and above that
um is being covered by others these are
the problems we could solve if everybody
who donated to these various audits and
recounts
donated to something related to child
poverty or the environment or what it
like think about the problems we could
really be solving i do not know who they
are but i
know from the get-go there was a lot of
grassroots people
oh yeah i have been told that there are
people sending in 10
50 checks 100 because they want to see
this on
i'm imagining some little old lady in
texas you know saying well i really need
them to do this i'm going to send them
from my fixed income
20 bucks fans decision to continue with
this audit is backed by the republican
majority in arizona senate
all right anyway you guys get the
picture so that's that it's all
disgusting
big thank you to adam gordon adam just
signed up at joinedpakman.com with the
coupon code better21 and his new member
number 22 today i appreciate that
also thanks to a white uh black white
rook
for 17 months subscribed via prime new
member number 23
and josh the jerk thanks for the prime
sub new member number
24. um okay then
by popular demand people liked this
yesterday this is a really short one
here is my interview
when i interviewed that white separatist
craig cobb who wanted an all-white
community in south dakota
here's a classic from the archives take
a look at this craig
cobb who is a member of the creativity
religion
involved in non-military democratic
village building
in leith north dakota and who says it is
supremacist for the government to test
its social theories
on unwilling human subjects uh
mr cobb you're a self-described white
supremacist
i don't even understand the introduction
to be perfectly frank
what does that introduction even mean
early 60s you've started buying up these
lots of land kind of southwest of
bismarck
what's the what's the goal here are you
trying to create kind of like a white
enclave there
yeah that's correct david and actually
in terms of my being a white supremacist
as a member of the creativity religion
we are more white separatists we don't
want to lord over other
races we just want to be away from them
right we have our own liebenstrom our
own space
so how did you develop this i mean i'm
so interested
in extremism and we're actually having
someone in a week
next week who's going to be on who was
born to extremist parents and actually
realized
the insanity of the situation she was in
and was able to leave
did you have racist parents or how did
you get into this white separatist
movement
no i didn't have racist parents or
racialists i uh
grew up looking at like life and look
magazine you know in those days that's
how we got information
photo spreads and such and i remember
looking at pictures of rudolph hess and
seeing
photo spreads made him racist in spandau
and then i wondered to myself even
though i was only 11 or 12 why
a man would be kept in an entire prison
like that and then later
a few years later after the cities
burned in the riots of 65 through 67
i became a supporter of george wallace
who said famously
making a dime's bit of difference
between the two parties well now there's
not a wooden nichols difference
yeah no i understand you know i i talk a
lot on this program about how
increasingly democrats and republicans
are both beholden to the same corporate
interest and all of that stuff
but that doesn't necessarily get me to
hating
jews and uh distrusting women right i
mean it doesn't that doesn't i'm not
seeing the connection like how did you
decide
that you don't like jews and white
people should have their own place to
live
well they've slaughtered very many
whites 20 to 30 million
in the ukraine the gulag under the nkvd
kaganovich and
laventry barrier under stalin and
the western europeans saw that and they
reacted and of course
a province of germany was ruled by
bolsheviks at one time people
do not want that they went to estonia
for example and matriculated with phds
in the late 30s
they were given autonomy by the
estonians and they paid them back
they thanked them by coming back with
molotov in 1940 with michigan anybody
following this at all like i still i'm
not following it
seen guns in the streets and nailed
babies into the trees
right but mr cobb mr cobb in the
interest of keeping us focused
yes late 1930s matriculation
again for most people it doesn't lead to
them hating jews
i just i'm trying to see today in other
words like what's your grief
with jews today well they control the
top 10 universities the law schools and
graduates of those schools become
arbiters of thought on here we go
television and in our court system okay
now now we're getting into the meat of
it
okay so let's explore that term control
right because this is actually i hope
the audience is paying very close
attention here because
oh the audience is riveted this idea of
control
is very common to anti-semitic beliefs
and kind of conspiratorial thinking
which is
if we can acknowledge that there are
any number of different groups from
particular socioeconomic ethnic or
religious backgrounds
who tend to do better or worse in
certain areas of
life that's one thing but then skipping
to this idea of the conspiracy of
control
is where things seem to go off the deep
end so talk to me about that
where is this idea of the conspiracy to
control coming from this is like
pure anti-semitism compared to some of
the stuff we see which is like
veiled well let me
backpedal to your term anti-semite when
a jew tells you
that you're an anti-semite what he means
to tell you is that he's anti-white
that's critical explain that so like for
example i'm i'm you're saying that
because
i'm jewish and i use the term
anti-semitic i'm actually anti-white now
what if i use that term about someone
like for example
um who who isn't white right if we talk
about whoever it might be louis
farrakhan or whoever
am i still anti-white when i use that
term
well louis farrakhan understands zionism
very well he's a very a great man for
his people
he likes louis farrakhan of course
that's a classic of course
of course i i think david you're not
much semi you're ashkenazi and kazar mix
oh that's the kazar myth yeah oh that
he's like i'd forgotten he brings up the
qazar myth
so really they're very relatively few
semonites
in israel about four-fifths some are
descended from ashkenazi jews
this is the kazar myth which is meant to
claim that ashkenazi jews are not
uh really yeah okay so this is this is a
known thing you can just
just google it uh the cause arm kazar
myth a lot of them from poland actually
and so when they say anti-semitic you
know they're including uh
semites arabs a lot of people don't know
that arabs are semites
right so it's a it's a lying term
and it's a manipulative term okay so you
don't like the term but we're not really
getting into the control issue because
we have limited time i want to touch on
one other thing
um you're wanted in canada right now
oh boy why not go to canada and face
justice and face the charges that are
against you right now
i will go probably when i'm 90 or 100
years old
i will tell you when you say i'm wanted
in canada that's for a so-called hate
crime and just like gay
shocking so many other terms these are
terms devised by
jews to oppress whites okay let's stop
right there though hold on a second
because that's that's huge
i want to touch on that so the term gay
is a term devised by jews to oppress
white people expl let's explore that in
detail
well when you're teaching kindergarten
boys to have flaccid sphincter muscles
look what's gay about it they have high
std they have high alcoholism high rate
of sexual partners
high rate of dying from aids high rate
of suicide man what's gay about it and
i'll tell you an example on that
is uh in estonia they had an
organization called licked but hold on
whoa whoa whoa whoa we i i need to keep
the focus
let's put aside estonia for a second and
flaccid sphincters or whatever it is you
want to you're not talking about that's
what homosexuals have but hold on a
second the question is
how when and how and which jews
developed the term
gay in order to oppress white people
uh you know i don't know the etymology
of it but i can tell you they invented
the word racist it was max
eastman trotsky's translator in 1932.
but you brought up you brought up gay so
i just wanted to follow up to see if you
had any
data on that it's ultimate i'm not sure
the precise etymology i actually
remember in the early 70s when they
changed that
term they're they're always uh
concocting terms now the one
is for hud affirmatively uh pushing
housing so what they're going to do in
all these communities like leith by the
way
perhaps is if your town is not 13
black and hispanic you know mexican
illegal or whatever they'll ship them
right in that's why they can call me a
neo-nazi
david and the associated press what on
earth does this guy talk this is a very
ill guy right
a few weeks ago stopped using the term
illegal alien as the university of
california but neo-nazi is fine you see
okay i got you well i don't know that's
exactly gonna happen
yeah right right right so i'm sorry what
was that last thing
i say that's [ __ ] wordsmithing you guys
you hear that huh
that's something oh i see okay hey so
last thing here um
you you as a logistical matter purely as
a logistical matter
how do you develop and learn about all
of this stuff you're talking about when
you don't have
like phone or running water and you live
in the middle of nowhere like as just as
a practical matter
yeah how did this guy become so educated
on these issues curious
well i have a verizon hotspot but i'll
tell you i live in the bakken and the
average wage up there is 71
000 per year there are 35 000 people in
williston making that money and this
town leith is very close to that we're
going to get white guys up there and get
them good jobs in the bakken
so uh bakken what word is that the
bakken
so weird i i'm seldom at my home i'm
usually working 70 hours a week
what kind of work do you like what kind
of work does a guy like you do
i was working for border states paving
in fargo and i was fired
because of my relationship imagine
you're resurfacing your driveway and
this guy shows up driving the truck can
you imagine
activities which propel me to do
political activities
yeah okay well listen
craig cobb you've truly said it all uh
we're going to
keep following this white enclave
community
as you know of course we didn't even get
a chance to talk about it but
it really does seem like it's just not
going to be allowed to even really take
place
and of course it never happened like as
an aside the entire premise for the
interview is a complete fantasy that
will never happen
but that's probably something you
disagree with and we'll have to save it
for the next time i know that you have a
lot to say about that
we're just out of time i wish we had
more but a there's a lot of controversy
we've been speaking with craig cobb
he is a member of the creativity
religion they are non-military just in
case people were wondering
we'll take a break and plenty more this
guy actually
is black that's the crazy thing um
check this out this is amazing
um i i think i even did a clip on it
yeah check this out this is my old club
i interviewed white
separatist or white supremacist craig
cobb he's the guy who wants to start
this where's the question
community in north dakota south dakota i
forget which one it is
so last week or the week before this is
just wild
uh t where's the original video
does tyt play the clip let's see the
leader of a white supremacist movement
oh yeah here it is check this out he did
a dna test turns out he's black
craig paul cobb has undergone dna
testing to determine genetic ancestry
86 european
and
[Laughter]
isn't this the best this is just one of
the best
[Applause]
give it to him give it to him 14
sub-saharan africa
i guess he's not allowed to live in that
community he's trying to create in leith
or wherever when in the dakotas
um man that is something else huh
[Music]
[Applause]
man that is just something huh
i don't know why but that is just
absolutely hilarious
uh so there it is yeah the racist guy 14
black and that's uh that's what's going
on wow
um all right thanks everybody sad that
we had to be together under
under what are tragic circumstances with
this shooting but we reviewed some
things
we chatted i took some messages from you
yeah this is
you know this is actually i i get that
let me address this super chat
do lesbians also suffer from flaccid
sphincters based on what craig cobb said
these anti-gay guys they almost never
care about lesbians and if you push them
on it like the immorality and all this
stuff
if you push them on it a guy like brian
fisher whose interview you
we reviewed yesterday he'll be like well
lesbians have problems too but
they don't it's not really homosexuality
it's it's
men it's male gay relationships that
they're obsessed with and that's like a
whole other
it can conversation for for a different
day um all right everybody thank you
probably stream tomorrow subscribe like
do all these different things just don't
email me spam
all right it's just it's oh oh oh oh
that's one last thing i want to do
check out this message i posted this to
my twitter
um this one came in from danny today
you're while you are the same disease
we the people won't gone
spreading lies and fear we the people
will stand together and
we are coming for you all
so that's on my twitter you i hope that
you guys are following me there
and then i posted one to my instagram as
well
[Music]
um
here's another one unfortunately i
caught 10 seconds of your show on monday
night
and you felt you had to explain marjorie
taylor green's comments to me like i'm a
child
wearing a mask is stupid and so is the
vaccine in case you haven't heard a lot
of young kids
are having heart issues from it they're
not even giving it to young kids
why don't you do what's good for you and
leave us alone we are all adults and we
know what she meant
to say thank you for your translation i
can't wait to hear more profound
translations from your dumbass mouth i
think you were part of the nazi regime
you sure sound like it don't tell me how
to think
you effing clown nice blue shirt by the
way you're kind of attractive
for a dumb ass for a dumb ass
all right i'll leave you guys with that
uh see everybody tomorrow